This is something that
everyone contemplates, like
what makes you conscious?
What is the soul? Is that a real thing?
What is, what is your consciousness?
Is it's simply just your own biology
trying to calculate your environment and
looking out for its best interests and
trying to procreate and move forward with
the,
the genes that had has,
or is it something almost
mystical or far more complicated?
Maybe even instead of the word
mystical might be tainted,
maybe something far more complex than
we're currently able to understand.
I think to some extent I would he agree
to it because it's suddenly different.
I need to have some internal
perception of the external world and,
and be able to think abstractly
and all these things.
It's surely different from way a baseball
runs through the air and what makes it
spin and and different than
every other conscious animal.
I'm not so sure about that. So I think the
difference isn't that big real. I mean,
okay, we, you know, we
use language to a degree.
I mean some animals use
language to some kind of degree.
There's a huge difference in degree.
I'd agree with that.
But whether it's a difference in kind,
I'm not at all. Sure. Um, you know,
you watch these nature movies
and I remember seeing one
about elephants and this
was about how the elephants were,
there was a,
there were always led by a
female elephant, and that's
not relevant to the story,
but they were trying to go from a to B,
I don't know maybe what it was. And they,
there's a whole herd of
them then we doing that.
But then at a certain point they made
a detour and they went off to a place
where the leader of the elephant herd,
her sister had died.
And the, the bones tusks, I
suppose with their bones. Anyway,
we're there and the elephants pick
them up, handed them around and,
and seem to caress them
and move them around.
And then they went back and joined to the,
the route that they were.
Now what does that tell us?
There's something going on,
which is not just some
machine behaving like a robot.
There's some, some feelings there
that we can appreciate. I mean,
another one I remember was one with these,
uh,
hunt African hunting dogs
and the dogs you see there,
there's a route where some antelopes we
tend to go net to go across the river.
And when they got to the point where
the crossfit and that slow down and,
and make their way to get across now
these hunting dogs, you could see them,
I think it was taken from the air and
they would go along towards this place
where the river was and then
they would break into two.
So half of them would
go one way towards the,
and they will hide just where the river
starts and the other half would go and
chase the antelopes.
They'd gone back and make an awful
noise chasing them right there.
And then the other ones were pants on
them. I mean there's something there,
which is, you know, there'd been
working it out between themselves.
How to do as commute
communication of some kind. Yes.
And I think there is, what would
you call understanding. Okay.
It's a more primitive level and then
human understanding. But nevertheless,
there was something, there's
no sort of clean dividing
line in my view. It's, it's,
it's pretty continuous. Yeah. And this
exists in wolves as well, so very,
very similar behavior and they do seem
to have not just verbal but nonverbal
communication.
They seemed to have some understanding
of what the task is and what their roles
are in the task.
And even though there's not as many
variables maybe as human life there,
there definitely seems to be a conscious
awareness of, first of all, their,
their position in the hierarchy of
the tribe of the pack reminiscing,
but also their,
what their objective is this,
this is not a selfish objective.
It's a group objective and they operate
as a group and they do move like those
African dogs you were talking about.
Yeah, no, it's fascinating. Love. Yeah.
And there's a lot of indication that uh,
my certainty,
chimps and elephants and things
and dolphins, we know about them,
but I imagine it guys quiet file down.
I should think.
How much have you studied a Octopi?
They're fascinating. Yes. No I haven't.
There's a new book about them, which I
haven't gotten the chance to read yet.
I wanted to read it. I think
they're, they're highly
intelligent. Yes, yes. Yeah.
I've only different really paying
attention to them for a few years.
I have a good friend. My Friend Remy
Warren was doing a television show, um,
called Apex Predator.
We studied the way different animals
hunted and he started studying the way
octopus and um, uh, cuddle fish
and all these different, yeah,
different,
uh,
Octopi and w the way they could adapt
to their environment by changing their
actual,
they'll not just the look,
but the texture of their skin
instantaneously and how this is not really
understood how the, not only how they
do it, but how they know what they're,
what's below them, what
they're copying. Yes.
That they somehow or another can figure
out how to blend in almost perfectly
with their environment.
It's amazing, isn't it?
They also can open jars and
Lincoln climb out of tanks.
There was one guy had a,
he had a camera on his tank because he
had two tanks and one of them had very
expensive tropical fish.
And the other one had his octopus and
he was trying to figure out what was
happening to his expensive tropical fish.
We put a camera on it and the
octopus was climbing out of the tank,
walking across the ground, climbing into
the other tank, killing one of the fish,
eating it, and then going back into
his tank. Yes. Yeah, that's heavy.
Well, there's one I saw, but I think
I heard the description or I read it.
I think I read it about some experiments
on testing the intelligence of
octopuses though,
and they had a digital thing.
They had to pull the chain and then
open the door and getting food out,
and this octopus was thinking, damn, I'm
going to fed out with this thing and say,
Yank the chain.
It came right off and then it rose to
the top and started squirting all the
people in their white coats.
So I know that was pretty good.
You know, there's something else going
on than just there is something going on.
Absolutely.